[Musique]
encore quelques jours à patienter avant
que le père noël ne dépose ses cadeaux
au pied du sapin
à londres le centre d'art le centre oui
le centre d'art de vélizy villacoublay
on propose des ateliers sapin bonjour
madame bonjour caméline depuis le 2
décembre il y a comme un air de famille
qui flotte au centre d'art béliziens
alors un air de famille c'est le nom du
festival c'est un instant à vivre vous
l'aurez compris enfin mini qui est
ponctuel ateliers parents enfants autour
du sapin de noël
betty mais ce n'est l'artiste qui s'en
chargent nous l'expliquent
nous allons créer sur le sol même
parcours avec pour matière première des
rubans adhésifs coloré voilà donc on va
faire un parcours qui ira d'une pièce à
une autre peut-être on s'arrêtera sur
certains s'arrêtent euros sur des pièces
qu'ils ont préféré
on créera comme ça des chemins des
trajets qui vont d'une pièce à une autre
une oeuvre collective éphémère qui sera
fait avec du ruban utilisé par les
électriciens
mais dans son interview betty parle
aussi de pièces mais parce que le début
de l'atelier commencera avec une visite
des oeuvres de deux artistes groth et
mazeas autour du père noël et de cette
époque magique
le public pourra voir des photos et le
blouson du père noël
un père noël biker alors pour l'occasion
ils ont aussi créé un majestueux sapin
qui trône dans le hall de londres
un sapin tout en irlande c'est une mini
forêts en un seul arbre et à se perdre
parce que nous on aime bien et ses 2
de renforcer faut moins d'établir un
lien entre quelqu'un qui viendrait voir
une exposition et de bel objet qui
proposait en fait si on ressert un petit
peu les liens vers la cdu coup très
resserrée s'est tellement resserré
qu'effectivement vient s'opère
directement dans la structure les
ateliers ont lieu tous les mercredis et
les samedis jusqu'au 20 décembre
et dans ce festival il ya aussi des
ciné-concerts le 15 décembre ce sont les
triplettes de belleville et comme c'est
la fin de ce site loisirs je vous
propose de nous quitter avec un extrait
merci mélanie nous a reparlé de ce
festival on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
d'ici là c'est un excellent week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]